this match featured you taking a lead
him bouncing back you did it again he
came back again you did it again he came
back and finally you hit him one more
time in game 10 and this time he took
the lead now I know you're a basketball
fan but what were you thinking about
just this competitive match between two
great players yeah I was in terms of in
terms of basketball I guess we were
scoring on every every possession right
because we started off with two draws
and then the next 9 out of 10 were were
decisive and there were no consecutive
wins and the whole match which is just
pretty pretty sick so Joe yeah I was
really like you both team scoring on
every possession I won the first game
which was okay but the next four to be
honest I think he played a lot better
than I did and but fortunately I took
took the one chance that I had in the
final game and yeah it feels it was
pretty sweet we saw at the end there you
give the play Thompson fingers shoosh I
know your goal is stay warrior fan how
sweet did that feel well so I tried it
once before as as you all very very much
know it didn't it didn't work out at the
earliest I've given my opponents more
ammunition I'm sorry I'm sure he'll see
a lot Oh shushing